this is a really typical example and it
uses the laws in a very simple way
okay we've got an object we've got an
object and it
is four kilos so its mass
is four no problem
you get given some information about the
force acting on it
okay and the force varies according to
time
okay here's a pretty typical equation uh
what have i got
3t squared okay
i'm going to give you an initial
condition
when time is zero
i've got a velocity of two
what i want to know is if that's the
velocity at
time two sorry if that's velocity of
time zero
i want to know what's the velocity at
time for
simple enough question okay how do we
approach it how do we use these laws
okay have a look at the pieces you've
got
i want to get to velocity right i know
stuff about force i know the mass
okay so i'm just going to default to go
here
okay this doesn't quite tell me velocity
but i can get to velocity from
acceleration is that all right and i
know a lot about these two
so let's sub in what we know so far 12
t minus three t squared equals four now
instead of writing a you have up your
sleeve
all these different ways to express
acceleration
so you should choose the way that's
going to be most useful to you
okay now think about what you know and
where you're headed
what's that what's the final line going
to be
the final line will be v equals right
because i want to know a velocity
so therefore what i should pick is
should be something in terms of v
right then you think about what do i
know and the answer is i know lots about
time
okay so i should pick this one you're
happy with that
choosing the right form of acceleration
is one of the trickiest things to master
okay good now what do i do
i should rearrange a little bit
shouldn't i i've got dv on dt
i'll divide through by four that gives
me three
quarters t squared okay now
at this point you have a choice um
you've got two different methods right
what's the first method that jumps out
at you
integrate be careful this is this is
motion you can integrate like 15
different ways right so what should i
integrate with respect to
b good choice okay so i'm going to say
if i integrate with everything with
respect to it you don't have to
i'm going to get v on this side
right and then over here i have an
indefinite integral you're happy with
that
okay so far so good this is not hard
we can do this we could do this in our
sleep this is going to be
let's see three on two t squared
minus one on four t cubed
plus a constant so far so good not at me
yeah okay
good now what
i have initial conditions i have initial
conditions so i say when
t equals zero v equals two
so i say two equals
zero minus zero plus c so i have a
constant
okay pop that back in
and now all you have to do is say well
when what am i after time for
times four pop it in off you go no
problem i think what you end up with
is 10.
okay no big deal right now that's one
way
there's another way to do this and it
might seem a bit unusual but you will
see especially in the questions to come
it is far more powerful okay so that was
method one
here's method two okay
the point which i asked you what should
we do is this point
this is where it diverges okay
i don't have to go for an indefinite
integral have a look at this
look at this can you see what you've got
here
is you have a pair of boundaries a pair
of
a pair of boundaries actually you've got
a pair of t boundaries
and you've got a pair of v boundaries
you don't know what this one is
but that's okay you can use the other
three to find out just like you use the
other three here
okay so instead of
integrating with respect to t just like
that okay i'm going to write it like
this i'll multiply through by dt
i get dv equals three t minus three
quarters t
squared dt okay now that i have a dv and
a dt
i will integrate both sides with respect
to different variables
so be careful okay so over here
i'm going to be integrating dv okay
and over here i'm going to be
integrating three t minus
sorry minus three quarters t squared to
t
okay now the real genius part of this is
that i'm going to use
just like here i sort of slowly fed in
all of these different pieces of
information i'm just going to put them
all in in one hit
okay velocity it's going to go from
two to two to one
well i don't know but it's a velocity so
i'm just going to call that v
okay if you want to be really really um
uh
if i want to be more specific about it
you could call it the four
so you don't confuse it with the
variable because this is not a variable
it's going to be a number in a second
okay what are my time boundaries uh
zero to four zero to four
can you see that does that make sense so
you can see
these match up at time zero velocity is
two
at time four velocities i don't know but
i'll find out in a second
right let's integrate yeah what's the
integral
that's just a one in there right what's
the integral
it's v
whoops good yes
what do i get over here the same thing i
got on that side except i don't need to
worry about the constant right
thank goodness t squared
t cube and i'm going from naught to four
ah this is so much easier
okay once you wrap your head around how
this line works
okay what are you going to get over here
upper boundary minus lower boundary
v4 minus 2 okay what do you get over
here
you stick your 4 into this right and i
think you're
to get let's just do it 3 over 2 times
16
1 over 4 times 64
minus 0. what's this what's this
24 yeah
v4 sure looks like 10 to me